có nhà, em mặng, y hợi em của ông miệng xam.
Sao em tạm thống muyện năm 2018, đọng bân xam,
xin năm 2017, chú xa mình dược, tính giữa tượng lên quan đến vụ chức người xe ra
tối nghiệm bày thống muyện năm 2018 đã đến công an xa mình dược, ra lai.
Đầu tụ, chứ đó, bà tối nghiệm bày thống muyện năm 2018,
tạc quan ông núng không thuộc thuộc dưới tây xa mình dược, đọng bân xa sẽ ra
một tưởng bình huyến quan s, xin năm 2017, chú cùng xa.
Tại đây, xa lấy xa cho quan dự đánh x, được một số người trong quan cân hân nên xa mừng lại.
Đi đó, thế x dự đi đi quan xong nụ, em quan ông núng không,
bởi phương phích nền xa được khiến xe ô tốt bệm bày a ba một hai hai bốn lào về phía x.
Sẽ trẻ thằng với cho quan xong nụ, tốt trung xa ba ba lưu thị quý,
xin năm 2017, chú xa mình dược, đào đối trong quan.
Hầu quan bà quý bị tương cấp dữ tại bệnh viện 2018, của người thị tự vòng xe bị tương.
Nhanh được tý báo, con hoa xa mình dương đánh trong có mặt tại hệ chương.
Tính hình các hả được đự chào, tổ chức chuyện tìm, bởi động tạng và sang gia đình đối.
Hình hình hình vực đăng được các quan công an tiếp tục đự chào, làm sao?